un grupo de estudiantes prepara una
cantidad considerable de masa conductora
una sustancia suave que puede conducir
la electricidad después moldean la masa
en varios cilindros con diferentes áreas
en su sección transversal
y longitudes l cada estudiante aplica
una diferencia de potencial del tav a
través de los extremos de los cilindros
de masa y determinan la resistencia r
del cilindro los resultados de sus
experimentos se muestran en la siguiente
tabla básicamente lo que están haciendo
es tomar este material esta masa
conductora y con ella hacen cilindros de
distintas áreas en sus secciones
transversales y de diferentes largos por
lo tanto varían las áreas de la sección
transversal y la longitud del cilindro
pero todos los cilindros están hechos
del mismo material después dependiendo
de cómo varían obtuvieron diferentes
resistencias los estudiantes quieren
determinar la resistividad
cilindros de masa recordemos la
resistividad es un concepto distinto al
de la resistencia una forma particular
de un material dado en donde tenemos una
longitud y un área transversal nos da
una cierta resistencia pero la
resistividad es una propiedad del
material y la relación entre la
resistencia y la resistividad es la
siguiente expresión r la resistencia es
igual a ro la resistividad que se
representa con la letra griega ro x l la
longitud del objeto al que le vas a
medir la resistencia dividido entre el
área de la sección transversal por lo
tanto si tienes una resistividad muy
grande y todo lo demás es igual entonces
tendrás una resistencia mayor si tienes
una gran longitud también tendrás una
resistencia mayor y si tienes un área
mayor entonces tendrás menos resistencia
si despejamos arroz podemos escribir que
ro es igual a r
por a / l
después nos dice indica a continuación
las cantidades que se pueden graficar
para determinar el valor de la
resistividad de los cilindros de masa
puedes usar las columnas restantes de la
tabla anterior según sea necesario para
registrar las cantidades incluidas las
unidades que aún no están en la tabla
pausa el vídeo y piensa cómo podrías
hacerlo bien puedo pensar en dos formas
de hacerlo puedes graficar puedes hacer
un plano coordinado donde en el eje
horizontal pongas l entre a y en el eje
vertical pongas la resistencia y la
resistividad será la pendiente de la
recta que mejor se ajuste a esos puntos
esa es una forma de resolverlo otra
forma de resolverlo sería poner en el
eje horizontal a / l y en el eje
vertical poner arroz
después intentar ajustar una recta
horizontal a esos puntos porque la
resistividad no debería de ser
dependiente de entre él y voy a optar
por esta segunda forma porque si voy a
hacer esta recta a mano es más fácil
para mí ajustar una recta horizontal que
ajustar una recta no horizontal en el
eje vertical pondré la resistividad y
tiene como unidades por metro y en el
eje horizontal pondré el área dividida
entre la longitud entre él y sus
unidades serán los metros para poder
usar estas variables esencialmente tengo
que calcular las tengo que calcular el
área dividida entre la longitud a entre
él y por otra parte tengo que calcular
la resistividad row si calculamos a
entre l tengo en mi primer renglón 0.00
49 dividido entre 0.0 30 que es igual a
1.016 dos cifras significativas aquí dos
cifras significativas en las variables
después calculamos rojo multiplicando el
área dividida entre la longitud por la
resistencia para el primer renglón tengo
la respuesta anterior x 23.6 que es la
resistencia es importante aclarar que al
hacer un experimento las cosas no salen
de manera perfecta hay un montón de
ruido en el mundo real
voy a redondear esto a 0.38 dos cifras
significativas bien seguiré haciendo
estos cálculos sin embargo para
ahorrarnos tiempo voy a acelerar el
vídeo en este momento
muy bien ahora podemos ir a la segunda
parte que dice en la cuadrícula
siguiente gráfica las cantidades
apropiadas para determinar la
resistividad de los cilindros de masa
escala y etiqueta de manera clara los
ejes usando las unidades apropiadas como
mencionamos en nuestro eje horizontal
tenemos el área dividida entre la
longitud cuyas unidades son metros
cuadrados / metros es decir metros y en
el eje vertical tendremos a la
resistividad es decir row
cuyas unidades son oms por metro ahora
tengo que pensar en las escalas si
pensamos en la escala del eje vertical y
regresamos a la tabla podemos ver que
todos los cálculos para arrow están
entre 0.30 y 0.41 y tenemos una escala
razonable por aquí veamos uno dos tres
cuatro cinco secciones entonces puedo
decir que este es 10 centésimos 20
centésimos 30 centésimos y 40 centésimos
para la escala de rock ahora para el
área dividida entre la longitud tenemos
si vemos todo esto en términos de
diezmilésimos entonces iríamos de 38
diezmilésimos hasta 160 diezmilésimos
así que hagamos esta sección 50
diezmilésimos 0.0050
acá 100 diezmilésimos
después 150 10.000 decimos esto es 200
diezmilésimos y 250 diezmilésimos ahora
que tengo las escalas bien vamos a
graficar los puntos el primero tiene una
resistividad de 0.38 y 160 10.000
décimos de metro para entre el si aquí
tengo 150 diezmilésimos y quiero tomar
10 diezmilésimos más entre este y este
para nuestra suerte está dividido en 5
entonces aquí tenemos a 0.0 160 y ahora
subiré 0.39 con metros
eso nos pone justo aquí aquí tenemos el
primer punto el segundo será 98
diezmilésimos y 0.31 98 diezmilésimos y
0.31 está justo aquí después tengo 0.41
para arroz y para entre el 0.00 66
66 10.000 decimos está aquí y después
tengo y después tengo 0.41 aquí y el
último 38 diezmilésimos y 0.40
por acá están 40 diezmilésimos entonces
los 38 diezmilésimos están aquí y nos
vamos hasta los 40 centésimos esos son
los cuatro puntos de los datos y después
nos dicen usa la gráfica anterior para
estimar el valor de la resistividad de
los cilindros de masa bueno como dijimos
la resistividad debe ser constante no
debe depender del área dividida entre la
longitud por lo tanto si queremos
ajustar una recta horizontal estos
puntos
bueno idealmente tendríamos que usar una
computadora pero como lo haré a mano
tengo tres puntos muy cercanos a 40
centésimos y un punto por acá abajo por
lo tanto tendré una recta más cercana de
estos tres puntos ya que son muchos
puntos por allí
así que mi recta se vería algo más o
menos así y este valor de aquí será
aproximadamente 0.37 por metro y lo
escribiré
y con esto hemos acabado
francamente otra manera de pensar esto
sería bueno podría hacerlo sin usar la
gráfica diciendo una buena estimación
para la resistividad del cilindro de
masa conductora es simplemente tomar la
media de estos valores
sin embargo nos piden que usemos la
gráfica e intentar ajustar una recta
horizontal
otra técnica usando una gráfica sería
trazar l / a en el eje horizontal y la
resistencia r en el eje vertical y
después estimar la pendiente de la recta
que mejor se ajusta a estos puntos esa
pendiente sería la estimación para arroz
aunque creo que eso sería un poco más
difícil de hacer que lo que hicimos aquí
eso es todo nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo